them for the mistake they're making
grammar the same grandma
they do they take some verses
that's also one of the prophecies
that Allah will make them spread
yes
from the word point of view of material
point of view that Islamic enemies they
have more
material than us they are the more
powerful in terms of resources resources
yes and especially than us so they have
more power to stop this time spreading
but Islam is
in the Quran
will enter people's houses
okay and you know what I was watching
the commentary this lady from a
Countryside Elites so she went to
University in Leeds then she spoke to
our family she became Muslim yeah and I
finally thinking when she came to see
them hijab the whole village
just have it's everywhere even though
there is a huge Angus snap rubber you
know you know in this war the war that
has been wasted it was worse understand
in Australia every day there's many
answers for speaking about itself
the response I get is don't don't ask
too many questions
one of my friends
foreign
look back and down
immorality has been pushed on the world
you understand
yes
or something
silly
[Music]
or wrong
foreign
as well
throughout the history
you can count how many times they're
happy to punishment against adult Trump
who's established because the condition
is very hard you understand so someone
who's been caught yes you open it you
understand
so there's no points
you can't understand something no before
that
I don't mind you I said to you sometimes
because we look at even influenced by
liberalism or secularism or atheism and
then we as Islamic news stations
opposing it so you as a person grew up
in this country know that you're gonna
think it's very harsh and it is
impression
no idea so you don't forget it
these days there's nothing great
punishments
so those days
photo
I've been so pissed off I've been so
devastating unbelievable
I will take that so much but if you said
to me
[Music]
I want to say
he's for these Believers
you you know you're okay do you get what
I'm saying okay my point here is again
it's emotional argument
yeah of course but okay emotional
arguments always valid or it can be
wrong obviously wrong that's it okay so
that's my point my point see what you're
doing again
you know my country
same inside
foreign
everything
does that Define being good okay this
example I think you heard it before if I
can send it back to my parents I reject
my parents he took care of me all my
life it's lovely sadly gave me water
loss thirsty when I was in need of
healthy they helped me when I grew up I
became healthy wealthy I stand away from
them I reject them and I take care of my
neighbors go away go away I take care of
my neighbors I'm not a good person
no no no no no think about that no no no
no no no no
they just take care of me all my life
they treat me well they gave me
everything I tell them
so the question asked himself tell you
Frank atheists you know in the Quran
Allah give you logical truth
why is worship alone why are you
rejecting it ask him if he's gonna tell
you I just I don't I can't be public
he's arrogant so you should not be
blaming Allah
when you put his personal fire because
all this person why are you in the house
Paradise but Allah can meet you now I
can choose to be careful I'm Muslim but
I don't have been here forever I want to
be in Paradise
but you know what is the biggest
Injustice biggest disability
adultery
you're in the house
you wake up in the morning in your own
house and there's a fire everywhere and
you're about to burn and you try your
best to serve yourself
and I cannot save your life
I owe you my life
so why don't you think and remember I'll
give you life for free
of course I understand
is that look how we you say I owe you my
life
but the one who gave your life while we
speaking brother yeah we are benefited
from Allah's blessings yes
so anyone doesn't want to stay away from
it except that he's out of it
foreign
but when it doesn't make sense it
doesn't make sense it's funny for me
like but I'm saying certain things
like for example foreign
first person human in history
I said to him how many years they said
infinite I said infamous
I says maybe six billion years far past
the weekend six billion years
600 billion years ago
100 billion years
but for some people not believing in God
fun
why because the one who doesn't believe
Allah because if he does that from his
side yeah it doesn't have ever of course
he killed people only because they're
not believing a lot there's others in
you yeah it's arrogance and that's a
couple of community
bring them back to life yeah they always
believe again and what's that for
eternity
because Essences of Faith also needs
everyone
but I'm saying in a human body okay you
know Peter Atkins Pizza Atkins is a
physicist Rich physicist he was asked an
interview oh yeah
Peter imagine you're walking and you see
the stars writing down Peter believe in
God he said I don't think it's magic
it's just like Allah said in the Quran
about that yeah
uh
should we follow
obviously
um
the one who gave them that time he has a
perfect knowledge
is
that you and I who has a little
knowledge to dictate to the one who has
a perfect knowledge what he should do I
agree I I believe I I know all these
doubts about the Hellfire favorite
Justice principle what life is all the
doubt but that doesn't mean let's
understand my plans Christian can come
now he said likewise God become a baby
you cannot utilize your brain no no no
no no it's not saying you know why
because it's different between what is
number necessity because for example
it's going to become a baby Define a
baby is created he's in need of help
that's already our future friends to be
good okay Christians can utilize this
argument this argument we're talking
about certain things is beyond our
understanding but does not of course our
sound reason make sense
and I always say
foreign
about lgbtq we'll go back to it yeah and
about adultery but you know what you're
doing sometimes not just sometimes
there is a decentralized human being
yeah
instead of centralizing Allah we
centralized human being what do what do
I mean by that and that inshallah will
break down everything there is more you
need centralized human being if our
starting points human beings we
therefore any legislation that punished
punish us we look at other bad things
because our starting point is we are
here to fulfill our desires but if we
centralize Allah I was starting our
starting point is Allah therefore we
have to fool Allah's Commandments
therefore delicious Nation Allah came
with will make sense
teaching
foreign
[Music]
his scholar for life I remember NASA
debating with my friend
and if he asked me a question and I said
wait wait
yeah
thank you for the information